uh you tell a story in the book about uh
a valuable lesson you learned on i think
the film was called
scorpion spring yes
yes one of these times when we have a
bright idea i had a bright idea
that went wrong it was a time early in
my career i had gotten out to la and i
was not
getting the jobs uh meaning i was
getting a call back a second callback
but not landing the job and i was tight
i was taking acting lessons for the very
first time learning finally what i'd
instinctually known how to do
previously well i get this blind offer
of this of this role and it's of this
drug runner on the border of mexico and
texas and
the scene is that coyotes bring across
his drugs he doesn't pay for him he
steals the drugs kills him and moves on
basically that's it well i get this
bright idea that look man
i've been tight lately i'm starting to
to take acting lessons i'm learning what
i'm doing and
this doesn't work i need to go back to
how i did it in the beginning when i
played wooderson days confused when i
had three lines and
i worked for three weeks and i just
improvised the scene because i knew my
man and i would just be me
so i said i'm not going to read this
script scorpion spring
i'm not even going to read the scene i
know the scenario i know my man i'll
show up on the day and i'll do what he
would do
ding right idea um
cut two i'm on the set of scorpion
spring i'm about to shoot that scene
well obviously i get a little bit
nervous because the pa walks by and says
you want to check out the sides and i
say yeah let me see the sides
i grab the sides i'm on my mark we're
about to say action i have a peek
one page two pages
three page four page monologue
in spanish
i feel this beat of sweat come up on the
back of my mirror and i remember saying
to no one in particular uh can i get 12
minutes
thinking 12 minutes was not long enough
to be an inconvenience to the crew
but maybe long enough to go learn a
four-page monologue in spanish because
hey i took the semester of spanish in
the 11th grade
well it was not long enough to learn
four pages in spanish and
i went back and did the scene i've never
watched it um
but i learned that day you've got to
prepare to have your freedom so i've
been a big preparer for my work ever
since because that was one of my most
embarrassing moments
you